the Joe Rogan experience what if I was
wanted to learn how to wrestle and I
wanted to be like a better wrestler from
France and I know I moved it I agree
because dc's as I was riding at Stevie
left yeah he's on his way out
Caine's there you already beat him there
dude that's what I say that's what I say
yes France but because he's [ __ ]
striking the power yeah it's just like
such a [ __ ] checkmate weapon then no
matter what anybody does you're always
ready for checkmate boom
it's like Wilder that kind of ridiculous
power you're always ready for checkmate
you're always ready Wilders is even more
impressive than Francis I don't know let
me tell you something that is 13 that is
cut to 265 my [ __ ] words if
Francis and Ghana decides to jump ship
and go heavyweight careful where you
going with this he will nuke some fools
nukes of the louder oh well it's kind of
a long time to get to Wilders level he's
not a world champion yes undefeated yet
they say but if Francis and look Francis
and gun was not ready to box with Walter
right now but let me say some starch in
30 say he might or he might connect no
he could kick this against was not the
slickest guy in the world we're not
talking about Muhammad Ali Olympic level
box lock Francis no sort of a year and a
half in he was in the Olympics but he
mostly gets by on power and range he's a
little bit Olympics medal but he's a
year and a half into boxing I mean I
think Francis probably could well for he
did know there's no doubt about it he's
amazing but if Francis has a problem
with grappling you think about what he
did what does he not have a problem with
striking he Kos Oulu see in the UFC true
true but Alistair Overeem is a
world-class striker I mean he's a
kickboxer at the highest level wins the
k1 Grand Prix I mean he's knocked out
Badr Hari he's beaten [ __ ] Turkish
Tyson for sure he's beaten some good guy
Freddie's a little older a little older
it was the other thing
if Alistair Overeem entered the boxer me
without with Deontay Wilder he went less
men I agree with you yeah however maybe
well if he can't his legs
no I'm straight boss or toddler but it
was in more time I mean it was an MMA
fight so he's allowed to do everything
great box and talking about apples and
oranges right but think about that if
Deontay Wilder fought alistair over him
in an MMA fight right now how do you
think that would go he'd finish him in
under a minute
he leg kick the [ __ ] out of Saint Hugh a
need you to take him down Chuck around
three seconds but he couldn't do that
to Francis and Ghana couldn't leg kick
him couldn't keep him off him because
France is MMA but if this I'll stir and
and Francis went to the boxing arena
they get absolutely Anaya with you but I
mean the thing that's holding well
unless they focused on a for as long as
those guys did but the thing that holds
back Deontay Wilder from people like all
the boxing pundits praising him is that
they think he has awkward technique he's
wild
but his results are spectacular okay
Francis and gah knew everybody he
connects on other than Stevie goes
night-night
Steve a is the only guy steep a sea pay
survived steep a figured out how to use
his championship medal and his grit and
uses takedowns and and won the fight
Derrick Lewis takes home shots is just a
terrible fight that was a dud fight I
don't even think that counts that
doesn't get that fight is so that's such
a mess from top to bottom that was the
worst fight maybe in the history of the
[ __ ] sport I agree they didn't throw
anything was so but the problem with
that fight is because they're such
knockout artist you expecting such
fireworks dude it was a big
disappointment I said to everybody there
is not a [ __ ] way this fight can saw
it's and I said you can never say that
cuz it's us I know whenever you say
there's not a way this fight can suck
it's gonna suck so disappointed man
disappoint it was but then when he comes
back and he knocks out Curtis blades for
the second time you know which I thought
late blades had a way better shot at him
the second - I actually thought he's
probably beat him especially after the
Francis and Ghana fight yes but it
showed that or the display but it showed
that in Ghana has really got it back
together again and it's fight JDS they
moved it though it was supposed to be in
Vegas they moved it it's dangerous fire
JD yes it's right for both guys really
but yes yes indeed yes I just think in
Ghana house if you're gonna stand in
front of him man he's got
you something yeah that's the thing he's
one of those I'm gonna hit you with
something when he became I'll they
coldly [ __ ] yeah man and he thought it's
like blowout is so bad he really did
think that's what happened when you look
at the replay he clearly got hit with an
uppercut but like a shop there's
something like a car went almost it's
all it needs that guy all he needs to
touch you
he just sees and the more he does it the
more confident he gets in it the better
he's only been [ __ ] training for six
years
do you see him first John so bad in vs.
John Jones yeah what do think would
happen I think John will take it I think
John smoke some JAMA take him down
[Applause]